vincent piot qui au pied de football
stockée à l'est attention dans la foi
casimir vient vite mon vieux nous
t'attendions pour commencer un match de
football mais enfin finir tu seras même
le capitaine d'une des deux équipes ces
enfants vous êtes d'accord parfait du
musée au monde format de capitaine d'une
équipe de football il se passe des
choses très graves et que si bien
emmener mon fils mais je viens de croire
si effectivement dû les trouve plus
importante qu'un match de football ce
qu'elles doivent être très très grave et
oui écoute bien par là il faut que je te
parle en secret que les enfants vous
continuez à jouer sans moi je reviens
dans une minute du hasemi rejeté couteau
vieux mais bien tous mais plus mes plus
beaux jouets ont disparu casimir qui
tournait sur certains et tu as dû les
ranger dans un coin qui tu as oublié
lequel non non non les harmonies casimir
c'est un bon signe non mais je t'assure
que c'est certain les émirs tout il me
semble que tu as des soupçons sur
quelqu'un ouais je crois qu'il a un
grand nez des oreilles marot où qu'il
habite dans une malle a les honneurs au
non-cumul a vraiment dû exagere c vrai
les honneurs et parfois très difficile à
vivre et non il serait incapable de
voler des jouets de noël pourtant j'ai
vraiment entendu des bruits bizarres on
passe emprunte sa malle
simo sous forme s était là et bien il
retrouvera le musée louis xi foldès
casimir du à vienne la chance justement
tout à l'heure je vais rencontrer par là
bas alors j'allais le prévenir toi tu
rentres chez toi et dans un instant il
tend jouer quand je rentre tout de suite
ok et en soirée demande aussi aux
enfants de venir parfois ils sont d'une
grande aide pour monsieur fall mais ça
évidemment casimir à tout à l'heure à
tout à l'heure chez toi
[Musique]
oui oui
tu vas voir renard mais un niveau venir
avec monsieur fort mais si tu seras bien
obligé de me rendre mes jouets
c'est ce que tu dis je dîne à semoy
finir ma sieste
il ya vraiment des moments où ce renard
minerva
baquet du mais sous forme à son entrée
je suis content de voir entrer les
enfants leur tour il est là il est là à
l'élève depuis qu'il est là mais mes
deux qui voulez-vous balle aimé léonard
le coupable
attendez monsieur kazim que je veux plus
je n'ai pas encore posé par des preuves
irréfutables que soit le coupable donc
il est plus encore le coupable comment
aviez vous dit qu'il se nomme ni en
armes sous forme est
monsieur annales
je vous prie de saute immédiatement de
votre golf world
[Applaudissements]
décidément je ne ferai jamais finir une
sieste tranquille
qui qui sont tous ces gens écouter sur
les enfants et cotait moi bien je suis
mon look fun metz vous savez lui a
offert le plus grand détective du mode
13 en or est je suis bien en art le
renard les plus rusés du monde mais au
fait mais je le savais en famille mais
bon flair et et plateau le mien n'est
pas ma vie non plus bon bon bon écoutez
ça suffit il s'agit de retrouver mes
joueurs préférés
et pourquoi ces jouets sont il rejouer
on repasse tous sont tous tellement joli
bruit qui m'empêche de faire la sieste
au
menu halal mais vous avez un excellent
mobile on ya lieu
de subtiliser les jouets de casimir vous
permettez que je vais
je n'ai pas eu le temps de faire le
ménage c'est ma grille mais évidemment
mais au les afars quel esprit
mais oui avez-vous une moue tous pareils
jouer mais oui j'avais une très belle
maupeou blanche et bleue monsieur
l'eonia rendait immédiatement la météo à
cazaubon comme
dit ma moto mais c'est bien oui c'est ma
moto
quel est celui
d'une aviation j'avais une ambulance une
très belle ambiance la menace immédiate
la lumière bleue et tout au mieux bon
c'est bien la mienne ou c'est bien mon
ambulants et la retenue c'est ed oui
ça
c'est moi
et les bruits
exactement ouais je ne viens bien sûr
c'est ma petite heure comme pour arriver
de vita locomotive et alors qu'est ce
que c'est que ces faits soient mal
voilées ou c'est ça je la reconnais
c'est la mienne ma petite locomotive
quel est ce bruit
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de problème c'est ma petite
vache blanche c'est votre vache lâche
tout de suite les
vanniers j'avais tout vous jugerez vous
donner est jetée coach il faut remettre
la ligne on ne peut les faire lâcher
pour l'assiette tu vas tout cas mal je
le promets bon alors moi je promets de
ne plus faire sonner mon réveil à 2
heures du matin pour manger dit casse
toi oui alors parce que dès mon réveil
oui maintenant réveil ou les
quais
[Musique]